hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guests today are filmmaker Kevin Smith
Legend and his daughter Harley Quinn
Smith who is an actress she's a vegan
activist together they have a new
podcast they just launched called vegan
abattoir and this is a really fun
conversation I think you guys are gonna
enjoy it so without further ado this is
me Kevin Smith and Harley Quinn Smith
enjoy appreciate you guys coming out
here to talk to me today thanks for
having man when when when the kid showed
interest in doing a podcast which like
naturally you know made my podcasters
soul uh-huh
because she'd been on a few episodes of
SModcast in the past and stuff but when
she was like I'm thinking about doing a
podcast I was like what what like oh my
god I know a thing or two about that I
was so excited so when she narrowed it
down and created what we're calling
vegan apt wah one of the first things I
said is like oh yeah you have to have
ritual on yeah cool she was like why and
I was like because like in the space
he's the guy I said I did this podcast
as like a year ago and not a week of my
life goes by where I don't run into
somebody who's like I heard you run
rich halls podcast and it's always
somebody I would never expect like it's
not like oh there's my vegan friend who
said that did somebody like says does
him like watch you as well there was a
lot of reach in that pie you got a big
audience and yeah I appreciate that I
mean that means a lot coming from you I
mean Harley do you understand what your
dad created I mean he is like the
original when it comes to there's like
three generations of podcasting here
because your dad Kevin was one of the
very first like way way before anybody
was doing it to jump in and own the
space
and he really pioneered it and created
like everything that's happened a huge
debt is owed to you Kevin and you
personally like I was I wasn't super
early into becoming a podcaster but I
was very early in terms of being a fan
and your show was one of the very
first that I cottoned on to and and it's
been super inspirational to me and so
it's cool to be here with you know
somebody who goes all the way back to
the beginning like I'm I inherited that
legacy and it's made me better at what I
do and now to see you stepping into it
super cool thank you you know definitely
definitely explained how important he
was to the podcasting community many
times so yeah and I actually was going
to try to attempt to do a podcast alone
and then one day he came up to the
kitchen while I was making breakfast and
he was like so I have to be part of it
ya know he was like um I'm gonna be
really insulted I think no you you
actually said you're going to make a
mistake if you don't include that was
close to it I was like alright here we
go but I mean I'm honored and I'm now
very excited that we have this together
but he did make sure to explain his
importance to the podcasting community
to me and give his look you know how we
were talking about like oh your father
created something I created something
that this table rich that I'm kind of
wishing right now I'd create a little
differently would call me out public and
tell my secrets I did I was just like
look kiddo I was thinking about it like
you could totally do a podcast by
yourself and I applaud that but like
it'd be such a mistake not to do it
together I was like because like I'm a
vegan too and you flipped me too big
anism like you're vegan story like
changed my life and so I know the
podcasting space and I was like and
people would love to hear like a dad and
daughter talking together and stuff like
that I was like I'm not telling you what
to do but like there's there's a
marketing hook here that's so right he's
not right there no he was right now and
I think at the time I was like but you
know I then realized how awesome it
would be to have it together but also
cool it is to have the perspective of
somebody who's vegan for their health
and somebody who's vegan four completely
different right animal right so it has
like also just proved to be a really
good combination so for different
backstories so that's really cool but I
I was hesitant yeah I want to hear more
about that but my sense is as somebody
who's on the outside looking in and I'm
just meeting you now is one of the
incredible kind of beautiful benefits of
everything that that has happened to you
with the heart attack and going vegan
and all of that is what's occurred with
your relationship like this is really
like brought you guys close like it's
very sweet you know that you know you
got involved within this movement
because of your daughter and then her
insistence and now you're gonna do this
podcast like there's a there's just such
a like a bond there you know that you
guys can do this stuff together it's
really cool and I say that somewhat out
of like I have a 16 year old daughter
and my 16 year old daughter to want to
do a podcast with me I was like you
would have to move heaven and earth I'm
nearly 21 so just give it like a couple
more but it has been really cool it's
been really special to be able to do it
together and I didn't really give my dad
a choice at all to be vegan I just I was
insisting upon it so but it was green
ruled it's like you're gonna go vegan
alright but initially right you said two
months or something like that but I was
never really gonna but I wasn't gonna be
like please right now commit to a life
time of veganism because I thought I
would scare him right but I did just
kind of pose it as a few months but I
mean it's been like to you yeah I mean
even you couldn't have imagined that he
would have he would become like this you
know basically you're now you're now
like the new face of veganism like it or
not Kevin like oh she knew and flipping
more that she would like he'd be a good
gift I'd I was I was like this is
important
he's got a big mouth he's talking about
his interests and veganism was one of
his interest that's good for me and my
community huh so she kind of saw like
the benefit of that but I I would like
to believe at the heart of it she was
just like you know oh my god I know a
way to keep you alive like I had almost
died clearly because I was ingesting
like not just animal food products but
far too many animal food products over
the course of a lifetime so even the
nutritionists in the room at that point
was like you know they plant-based diet
will bring your cholesterol down and
that's where she saw the opening and was
like yes one of us one of us so you know
I said look I hate the way that I ate
for 47 years
I'll give this six months like you know
I can the least I could do is try your
way for six months why not and that was
two years ago let me see February March
April May June July so two years and
five months ago and I haven't missed
anything that's the question I get the
most from people about veganism is it's
like what do you miss bro what do you
miss like your daughter's not here what
do you really men that's true they know
that [ __ ] like you're the dude commissar
of all this they're like you know as you
said like he was going vegan for life so
they know like now I have two bosses in
life not just your mother but also you
so when I come on dude what are you
really think and I honestly don't miss
anything there's nothing that I'm like
oh man that's the thing that people are
surprised about because they they
suspect that you're just walking around
creating in and out yeah like your whole
life you're like I'm living a half or a
quarter life where I can't enjoy food
anymore like lately we live in
California and so they've got this
veganism stuff down to a sign it's
really tasty but even without that like
even if you're just like look I can't go
to some high-end restaurant where they
take a kumquat and turn into a meatball
so what do I do
beans and rice man like yeah tastier
than most stuff that I ate on the non
vegan side you know and like that's
seriously my go-to like for the last
month that's all I've been coming the
last time last time I saw you was at the
Mercy for Animals gala thing and you you
got up to the podium to give away like
the hero word or something I can't
remember what exactly the award was it
you gave away but you
something along the lines of if somebody
told me if I went vegan I could I'd be
sitting next to the Joker walking I was
like don't don't don't tell them I'm the
Joker as if they didn't know her fear
but yeah the benefits that come with it
you know of course the health benefits
are a number one for me it'd been
obvious like I dropped a bunch of weight
and like in my behind-the-scenes life
where the what's not so obvious is like
my body chemistry and I find that out
when I go to the doctor all the time
and dr. laden Himes the guy that saved
my life my cardiologist every time I've
gone for the last you know you do
six-month internal check ups he's always
like whatever you're doing keep doing it
and the first time it registered was
like when I went vegan for two I was
vegan for two months and I went in for
like a blood test and he was just like
oh my god everything is great except for
your cholesterol and I was like well we
knew that that's why I had a heart
attack he goes no your cholesterol is in
the toilet then what happened he's like
it dropped out and I was like I went
vegan he's going well I got a cut here
at the mat some meds and a half because
whatever you're doing is really doing
the job and so I've gone back you know
every six months for another checkup and
the last one I had was right when I got
back from the tour so it was like at the
beginning of March right before
everything went into lockdown and he was
just like your blood work is phenomenal
like you know he's like and he even said
because Harley always picks at him
because early on I was like I'm gonna go
vegan and doctor late and I was like you
don't have to go vegan it's nothing
wrong with me which is astounding until
he goes just keep it in moderation you
know it's like there's nothing wrong
with me
so he later you know it was like look
[ __ ] me like going vegan was the right
move for you like I can clearly tell so
he has since like tell your daughter she
was right yeah passed on where are you
what's going on with the meds now are
you still on some magic just cut my
blood thinners down substantially but
yeah I'll be look I'll be on blood
pressure medication probably my whole
life just because of my family history
at this point and because I'm you know
heart attack victim or whatever things
so I'll definitely be on blood pressure
but blood pressure medication probably
for the rest of my life whenever I go to
like to a physical I got to get a
physical for Jay and Silent Bob reboot
the doctor was like oh my god you you
have the blood pressure of a man on
blood pressure medication well done yeah
thank you the blood thinners the doctor
cut down they put you on blood thinners
because they put a stent in my el-ad
and they don't want the blood to
coagulate block it and run back in the
same situation so I've been on blood
thinners for like two years but he
recently dropped those two like half
doses yeah which is good because like
I've shaved quite frequently and
periodically and Nick yourself and when
I nicked myself it was just like a
geyser of red blood thinners and stuff
and then there's a cholesterol blocker
whether it breaks up the cholesterol
it's in my system and I'm not I'm
certainly not a wizened individual I
can't speak to body chemistry but the
way I understand it maybe I'm wrong is
the cholesterol that was in my
bloodstream will always be in my
bloodstream it doesn't go away the
cholesterol medication that but they put
me on breaks it down into a you know
more liquid form but it's not like and
now it's out of your system yeah like
it's still circulates and why they want
it to break down is because when it's
hard the plaque is hard that's the stuff
that travels through your circulatory
system can lodge in your brain or give
you a stroke right so I don't like I
always like to think like you know my
cholesterol is gone but the way I maybe
I'm wrong I think it stays in you I
think once you've done the damage the
damages is done and at this point all
you can do is not create more damage
yeah maybe I'm wrong I don't know I'm
not a doctor
[Music]
but Harley
why don't we I want to hear more about
like your story with this because you
you you became vegan for ethical reasons
when you were quite young right yeah I
am a vegetarian yeah my mom's a
vegetarian she's been a vegetarian my
whole life so she's definitely had that
influence but it wasn't really I wasn't
really aware of her influence until
after I went vegan I just I thought I
didn't really it's funny
because it's the one thing like you know
my wife her mother is always like she
lives in the shadow of both me and her
daughter uh-huh you know because we both
do public things yeah and so you know
her I think the thing she craves most in
life is like recognition because she
stands in the shadow to people who get
recognition just sometimes for waking up
and yeah so like her her being an
example that set Harlee on the road to
veganism would mean and does mean
everything to Jen but the way that
Harley puts it where she's like really
think about it until later on so I
always credit her now and that's why I
like I do always I'm so vocal about her
inspiration to me but like it really
wasn't something I was aware of because
she never was like hey you maybe
shouldn't eat chicken or she wasn't ever
trying to push her ideals on me she was
only in milk that I never wanted it was
so questionable to me anyway anyone but
as a kid it would have been question it
was always questionable I had it once at
school and I I spit it out cuz I was
like what at age what five or six yeah
cuz yeah but if you were like me I
probably like rich you had been raised
with milk it never would have been like
this is disgusting to like you know yeah
we were just giving milk from young
right it wasn't until I became a
grown-up went vegan stepped out of like
the food industrial complex and the milk
industrial complex and was like kind of
[ __ ] up no mom definitely made me
aware of that and so I I'm thankful I
always had that awareness but she never
said anything about me mmm any other
animal products so even though she
didn't really meet herself no she never
ate me ever so I didn't I wasn't aware
that she was influencing me but I think
since she is my mother and I'm always
gonna look up to her and I looked up to
her in so many other ways I probably
subconsciously was inspired by her
choice to go vegetarian I think that did
secretly subconsciously influence but I
just had no idea until later in life
because I witnessed my my mother who
raised me not eat meat for 20 years and
so I'm sure somewhere in me I was like
oh well she's been doing it for as long
as I'm alive so I probably can do the
same but so she definitely did influence
me I just wasn't aware of it at the time
but now I definitely do give her all the
credit she deserves where she's broke
1-0 where God finally they acknowledge
where but what really made me go
vegetarian at first I've been vegetarian
for over five years I think now and I
just hit my 4-year vegan mark in April
but was adopting my my rabbit because
when I adopted her she was fully
traumatized before she was surrendered
to the shelter I adopted her from she
was being held by hoarders who had like
a hundred other rabbits and she she was
so terrified of all of us she has a
ripped ear she had a bunch of metal
stitches that weren't tended to when I
adopted her she was covered in pee like
she was in a terrible terrible condition
and she was really standoffish to
everybody in our family at first when I
brought her home she was really scared
of everybody understandably and it was
really heartbreaking to me because she
she thought I was going to hurt her and
that that of course broke my heart
because I wanted her to feel safe so
after months of making her know that I
was never gonna hurt her none of us were
ever gonna hurt her she wasn't ever
gonna be hurt again and that I was just
showing her so much love and compassion
she transformed into into a much more
open loving creature and kind of seeing
what human compassion could do to an
animal just gave me a new awareness that
I had never understood before we're by
human actions directly affect the
animals that we coexist with
you may not have understood that but you
had it in yourself all along because it
takes a very specific person to say I'm
gonna take the rabbit that's all beat up
from the shelter run a pet store and
getting the the rabbit that's all
groomed and cute
absolutely so that that what that is
clearly part of who you are thank you
I'm part poor dogs growing up were like
oh it took the rabbit like you realize
animals were important Thanks
he left the part out that you had dogs I
always but it's because all of but
before we knew before I was aware before
anybody was aware that it wasn't it
wasn't ethical to purchase an animal
rather than adopt we had bought all our
dogs so they didn't they didn't know
trauma they we bought them all when they
were babies and they came from a pet
store and they were probably not treated
well the pet store but they were all
really young and we but we paid money
for them like they they were they didn't
really know much trauma whereas when I
adopted my rabbit she was already two
years old and had to live through two
years of trauma and had PTSD so like I
was surrounded by animals but they were
all they didn't know anything except
love and happiness so like they were
great too they're great but it wasn't
they definitely I wasn't going to look
at my yellow Labrador and be like oh
what's your trauma what what have you
been through but I was looking at my
rabbit with a torn in half ear who is
traumatized and has PTSD and I I could
see that in her and and felt something
so yeah the dogs are awesome too like my
traumas that I live with a little girl
who doesn't love me
yeah calculus when choosing your
boyfriend yeah yeah he came into
quarantine with us and he's a like a
good dude I know I'm like as a dad I'm
supposed to be like I don't like this
guy making some kind of spoof at home
like you're all cramped up sir like
let's make a TV show yes yes TV show
called the celebrity show-off which is a
Americanized version of a Korean show
called my little TV where they get like
people ooh you know I hesitate to call
myself was like a celebrity but people
who like you might recognize and they're
since we're all stuck at home they're
like you can't have a crew we're gonna
send you a package you make a show in
your house uh-huh using what you got and
then every week people get you know
voted off like these are the best ones
this is the one didn't get the most
votes you get kicked off and stuff it's
like a ten week program contest every
week that we stay in like there's money
goes to charity and stuff like that so
you know when they presented it I was
like um all right yes I'm home I got
nothing to do one night so most of the
people were doing to camera shows
meaning like hi I'm this person and
you're in my house blah blah blah so I
was like wow if everyone's doing that
maybe we'll do something a little
different like you know it if I could do
anything I want let's do a little sitcom
like and we'll call it Sun and lockdown
and it's predicated on like Austin right
living with us like a fictional version
of Austin who's like really tough to
take so it would give me a chance to
like not just be involved the show but I
can do it with the family we gotta be
involved and stuff have a good time and
so if we kind of move forward with it
and it's it's been interesting man like
there
the show begins June I want to say 23rd
or something like that next week on TBS
but they put up the short that we made
uh-huh already online and I think that's
where people they'll see which ones are
popular or not or something so working
with the kid yeah I've worked with her
for but working with her boyfriend was
nice cuz we've just spent like you know
she's how long you been dating them
eight nine months or someone so I've
known him as her boyfriend in that
capacity and then I've known him as
somebody who lives in the house over the
course the quarantine that's completely
different when it's like alright now
let's act right you know and so I think
both of us got to like spend time with
each other in that way whereas like nice
but can I direct him that's literally
what it is he's like oh my god is that
how I kerttu you what it is my Christian
for that side worst night I act in his
projects when using a podcast together
now we're doing a TV show with my
boyfriend like is there anyone on this
side of the ask you know the view askew
universe what you missed though is a big
breakthrough moment and if we went to
therapy family therapy that would have
been huge where she really broke me down
to my essence to be like oh he likes him
now because he's it's it's it's
well-known throughout the house like
what do you mean other people talk about
this yes let's just take a moment like
my wife your mom what they've all said
the look I think I mean you definitely
liked Austin before yes yes but there
was an absolute new level of acceptance
where he was suddenly on my rage it was
suddenly not someone who simply lived in
our house but someone you could perhaps
love you if that only happened once he
gave you something what's I was like oh
he's not not only is he useful to you
he's useful to me as well and you love
him because he's useful to you it took
me time to be like Austin no but you're
me you're actually doing something for
him
like now the guy's gonna be on TV well
but he's the actor before like he was it
was scary
but he I mean he thank you rich that's
how I felt she's like he's been in a
Walmart commercial bro my guy he was
really excited because he was like I
mean is this a secret that you didn't
know I we we've all been like trying to
find a way for you to get closer to
Austin because like Nana and pop might
my grandparents my mom's parents are
really close with my boyfriend like we
we've traveled a naturally close it's a
little we might get my papa and my
boyfriend play ping-pong and like we all
play pool together pretty much every
night it's pretty cute and wholesome but
and then my mom has gone to know him to
buy by him living at her house and you
were kind of the last person where it
was like what and it's not like you're
not really the type of person who's like
let's let's sit down and get to know
each other like a bigger thing which is
that your dad is a closet grinder I mean
I don't know how much in the closet you
are about that and you had like to hold
yourself out I like to watch TV and sit
on the couch I'm lazy and all of that
but like you have this insane work ethic
I mean you came off you make the reboot
movie you do think crazy tore 60 how I
don't know how many cities yes 65 cities
then you're in lockdown when you're in
lockdown you're writing like a bunch of
scripts and making this TV show like
that's out of like fear that's like I
don't even know if it's a work ethic as
much as like I have to keep making stuff
because what if this doesn't work what
if this doesn't work with this doesn't
fear it's like I don't ever want to go
back to having a real job like you know
I still worry about that oh god yes
absolutely you might have to go get a
job I mean every day in my life I go
this maybe this is it this is the last
day where the light
we have no more [ __ ] use for you and
your silly stories and I look at my like
output and what I do and it is getting
more and more insular like you know Jay
and Silent Bob reboot was a fun movie
but it really helped if you'd seen 6-7
other meetings prior to that next movie
I'm probably gonna make is twilight of
the Mallrats we really help if you saw
mall rats which came out 25 years ago
I'm working on a show for Netflix which
is masters of the universe also comes
from IPE out of the 80s like everything
I do is predicated on the past or my
very small world of things so I always
wonder if like since I'm not really
talking about the future barely the
present but I'm never really like trying
to be a Chris Nolan who's like I'm gonna
make Tenet man and like it's gonna blow
your mind
sooner or later they're gonna turn
around and be like we'd rather use this
space for somebody with new ideas we
don't want to see clerks again so you
think every day of my life I don't fret
about it but it's definitely in the back
of my head that's what makes me work
where I'm like one day I won't be useful
to them and novo and will pay me to make
entertain them and I'll have to go back
to quick stuff and I don't want to do
that because when I go back to Quickstop
they'll be like hey Hollywood I guess it
didn't work out 30 years later I don't
want to eat crow thirty years after well
that is in large pardon I mean you you
dipped your toe and uh you know you made
the Bruce Willis movie and you know you
kind of explored that territory and it
was what it was but you know this this
appreciation for your fan base and and
the love that they have for the
particular thing that you do that nobody
else can do Kevin Smith I think there's
you know there's there that's beautiful
you know what I mean like you have these
this audience that adores you
and the fact that movies and you you do
them essentially outside of the studio
system you take it on the road and you
show up for those people in a very real
way like we were talking before the
podcast you like doing these live shows
there's a thousand 1500 people whatever
you stay after you're hugging hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of people like
that tactile like one-on-one connection
that you have with your audience is rare
and and special and the fact that you
care about that I think not only
distinguishes you from what people might
imagine you know somebody of your
stature or like Hollywood celebrity you
know thinks about and cares about but I
think there's more long I have a stature
you're yeah you're like you're your look
yeah come on your dad's a celebrity
right like people know who he is they've
seen your movies but I mean what is he
what does that mean at the end of the
day I don't know I don't know what to me
because I always think about it means
it's like I'm like I don't think I'm not
saying this like I feel old but it's
like all of it is it's old stuff well
it's it's ultimately it's meaningless
but I guess what I'm getting at is I
didn't mean wow you're really
instrumental you know like the value of
this in a world where you're not but
saying something new but always saying
something old or reminding people of
something old how much of a future can
one possibly have and yet this is the
weird conundrum of my life even though
I'm like engaged with the past I'm still
functioning in the present like I don't
understand why I still have a job or a
following because I haven't said
anything new in in years last new thing
I said was yo goes there's never one was
like shut up so like you know most of my
stuff is engineered to things I've done
before or things that have gone by even
comic book men the show we had on AMC
for seven seasons was a fun show but
like at the end of the day when I looked
at that show I was like this is also
nostalgia and sentimentality it's all
predicated on people bringing in old
things and us singing around going like
oh my god I remember having that so I've
come to grips with post heart attack
that is my role people are most
comfortable with me
talking about the past when I start
talking about the future they're like
hey tusks boy maybe not so much the
future with you but we love the 90s and
you were the man back then so now I
still am in the 90s business up I don't
think of it in terms of new and old you
know I think of it in terms of what
people love you for what they care about
like you're you know you have this this
you know kind of you had this mentorship
student relationship with Stanley right
like he was your dude so you could look
at him and say well everything you know
all the stuff that he was doing is in
the past it's not though it's in the
present as well it's very much part of
the consciousness like I don't think
that your stuff you I've it did his work
well you look at all this stuff around
us like this stuff has been around for
decades and decades and decades but
people don't think of it and here falls
on a timeline he got to see it embraced
by the mainstream he got to see his
creations embraced in two different ways
once when he first created him and he
had the comic-book marketplace to
himself and for years like those
characters were viable met him tons of
stories so he got to see that world
embrace those characters but then on top
of it he got to see the rest of the
world embrace his characters can you
imagine it's like you created Ironman
decades ago and you thought you've
gotten everything you can get out of
Ironman a bunch of comic books they did
him in as a cartoon there have been toys
and then one day somebody's like we're
gonna redefine this [ __ ] we're gonna
bring it into the people's real life so
much so that your mother is gonna know
who Iron Man is that it's Tony Stark and
stuff all of the dudes work got a brand
new lease on life and he was here to
appreciate it not only that they stuck
him into every one of those movies so
that people would play this Where's
Waldo game of like see that guy that's
Stan Lee he created these characters and
stuff nobody nobody gets to enjoy it
that good twice in a lifetime that's how
special that man was how beautiful he
was because it good things only come to
people that deserve it and that dude had
two brilliant lifetimes where everyone
stood up and was like you are the man in
two completely different eras he lived
long enough he was 95 96 almost when he
died but in two completely different
eras he was celebrated by two completely
different audiences
all encompassing audiences I always that
takes my breath away I loved when the
last one came out when endgame came out
the first thing they put up was the the
Marvel logo that was nothing but Stanley
Schatz from all those Marvel movies and
at the end it said Thank You Stan like
you heard [ __ ] people sobbing in a
theater for an old man who told them
some stories a few years ago like to
have that kind of impact in a life one
could only dream about being that guy so
believe me when I was ever whenever I
was with Stan I always kept an open ear
and an open eye because I'd love to be
that guy I'll never be that guy he
created like some legit characters and
make billions of bucks he created like
you know Iron Man spider-man co-created
I created James I'll buff so there's
worlds apart of course but even in just
in in terms of creating something and
standing by it he was also my role model
he was the guy that would tub them for
comics like I remember nine years old my
father waking me up and being like come
in come come watch Good Morning America
spider-man's dad is on TV and I know
exactly who he met and it was the first
time I laid eyes on him and here was a
grown-ass adult you know I'm a child at
this point he's a grown-ass man on
television and whenever I see television
the grown-ups generally speaking about
grown-up [ __ ] here's a grown-ass man on
television talking about [ __ ] that was a
interest to me talking about spider-man
talk about comic books start gonna
superheroes I fell in love like an early
age where I'm like that's who I want to
be when I grew up like if this guy he
can make it work every adult I knew was
so serious and so earnest and so grew up
they had to they the weight of the world
on their shoulders trying to support
families and stuff here was an adult
seemed like a grandfather figure who
talked and joyous terms about the [ __ ]
that meant something to you so I was so
happy to see across the spectrum of his
life particularly in the last 20 years
that the whole world knew his name
everybody knew this guy's name at the
end of the day in the comic book
community he was a god to us we all knew
his name that was Stan that the whole
world embraced that guy that meant
everything meant everything to him he
went out there you want to talk about a
work ethic Jesus I'm not God was 95
years old he'd get up he'd have a full
schedule of things to do and you know
maybe one of them had to
with making money the rest of them had
do with making people happy so if I can
live long enough where I can be that
functionary you know what I'm saying
like just like Stan his best creative
days were in the early days and then he
spent the rest of his career talking
about that time and being an ambassador
for comics in general that would be a
way to go for me if I can last in this
business as that guy that'd be amazing
but can you take even a fraction of what
you just said and apply it to yourself
because what I'm saying is if Stan Lee
came to you on the cusp of you know
being a God in the comic book world but
not yet embraced by the rest of the
world if he came to you and said Kevin
people only care about what I did in the
past nobody wants to hear about this
what would you say to that guy he said
we're insane I told him he was crazy on
one occasion we were having a
conversation and we were talking about
writing and you know Stan was always in
Stan mode and and he delivered the
exactly the person that you hoped to
meet when you met Stan Lee and you know
he talked about comics talked about
characters and stuff I known him across
you know almost 25 years so I got to
talk to him about many things and I
remember one day I having a conversation
where he was talking about feeling like
a failure because he had always wanted
to write the Great American Novel and
he's like and still I haven't done it
and I was like Stan like yeah overshot
the Great American Novel
I'm created the Great American mythology
you know most of the book [ __ ] a book
you created a religion like it look how
it's gonna speak for hundreds of years
after your passing my passing like you
did write the Great American Novel and
it's a it's a [ __ ] comic book and you
did it again and again could he hear
that
look Stan Lee knew exactly who Stan Lee
was you know like Stan Lee created many
great characters but the greatest
creation of Stan Lee was Stan Stan Lee
himself Stanley Lieber created Stan Lee
and war Stan Lee like a costume like
that sweater he would put on so I
guarantee you that Stan knew exactly
that he had overshot the book but you
know we're creatives at the end of the
day take everything away stan is a
creative and wasn't creative and
creative as an ego and an ego likes to
be stroked so in that moment Stan was
just like I didn't how this is we rarely
get a chance to do this
how has your journey been I had
mentioned that beginning the podcast
like how well travelled that episode I I
did was how I found as I went out in the
world when I went on the reboot Roadshow
tour a lot of the people who I saw
afterwards the during the VIP experience
people come and take pictures with you
backstage and stuff like I loved you on
ritual like you know and some people of
course like they look healthy and stuff
so that makes sense but just in general
man like how have you found functioning
now in the real world like that for lack
of a better description of you your
famous Harley you see what he's doing
right now you just did
exactly you just illustrated the story
it installed and being a true podcast
host you're trying to flip it oh my god
I'm always more comfortable to you for a
second I turn it back on you very kind
of you thank you
it's wild you know this medium is so
much more powerful than I would have
ever imagined getting into it what about
during quarantine have you found more
activity or interactivity or less
interactivity with the shows since we've
all been unlocked in um it's it's
remained pretty much consistent there's
a little bit of a dip I mean people's
listening habits change because they're
not communing and they're not going to
the gym see I would have put it the
other way where it's just like
everyone's got more free time in their
schedules so that's that's been a little
bit of a shift and then we all had to
kind of go and do some calls and all
that kind of Jon Kerley and I were
talking about ahead of time and I was
like done with that so yeah here we are
the delay the antibody test though we're
all healthy we did I'm wearing a
band-aid because we got an antibody test
which it was a good to have but be
depressing to learn that I have not had
had it you
both you convinced that you had it yeah
that's crazy that you didn't after go
into all those cities a lot of other
activity with a lot of different folks
and a lot of different weather climates
and you know now they're saying that
like the you know we keep marking you
know kovat coming into the country from
late February into March they're saying
now some cases they believe predate
earlier years yeah like you know there
was a I think the ha reporter did a
piece on there were a bunch of people
sick at Sundance in January right and a
lot of these symptoms are the same I was
there you know I remember interviewing
what's her name um Julia Louie Dreyfus
and she was like really sick but like
she was trying to soldier through for
the movie she was there for so it might
have gone back as far as that so I I
would have been sure that somewhere
along the lines that I had it although
not as bad as right we've we've seen
other cases but apparently not so we're
right for the taken and you know based
on the news reading this morning we
should all be staying inside a lot
longer we're talking about going to do
this at sideshow because I'm engaging in
the world I'm wearing a mask when I go
out and stuff but I've gone to do stuff
still and maintained like streaming
schedules and but Harley has really
treated lockdown very seriously yes how
has it been for you it's been it's been
really hard for my kids yeah I think I
think the most difficult part is that I
just feel so protective over my
grandparents and they live with us and I
just can't bear the thought of one of my
actions leading them to suffer from
kovat so I'm not really scared I really
genuinely thought I had it because I did
get sick at the beginning right after we
got back from New Orleans went right
after Mardi Gras we were there the day
after so and I did get sick so I really
thought that I must have had it
the test was like a good-news bad-news I
know I know I wish I'd been sick but
it's
I'm not scared about myself getting it
or my boyfriend I am kind of scared
about my dad because of your heart yeah
for a while not scared but I I I kept
hearing about like it's young people and
old people I'm like mom right in the
middle and then they're like it's also
people who suffer from things I'm like I
don't suffer for anything you know like
it's also people who have had hard
satuay
wait that's me I feel really protective
over everybody else and I can't control
my dad so he does go out he's safe but
like I can't if I had a choice I would
be like please stay home we got home one
of our only fights over but do you want
to mention flew across the country
didn't get tested came to our house the
day after like after flying after coming
from New Jersey which was initially
whatever he was flying and then he came
to our house the day after and I was so
mad I first came in silent treatment I
hate your face I ignored him I saw him
like we were going on this this walking
route every day then we would go
sometimes together but sometimes at
different times and my boyfriend and I
were coming back home while him and his
friend were going up the hill and I just
to even talk to me I just because I
decayed me like don't know I was just so
protective over my grandparents and it
was scaring me so much and I I could
pretty much ensure that they weren't
gonna leave at all they had like one
doctor's appointment that they had to go
to but other than that they were home
and I could like sanitize everything
that came into the house for a while
yeah
it was very much controlling the
environment and then my dad just brought
this whole other factor in which I was
like what the [ __ ] this is so I just
felt so blindsided and so betrayed
and there was she was very like she
wrote this text group text to the family
about me where I was like um you could
have just talked it was a dogfight
that's your job you know until your
parents are knuckleheads and don't know
what they're doing like this is supposed
to happen yeah but I think it's also
like very confusing there's the goal
posts are always moving you know the the
information that we're getting is always
changing and you know we can always
default to being as protective as
possible and obviously it's much more
heightened for you having your
grandparents there and the stakes are a
lot higher but you go out into the world
and it's like some people are in Mascis
some people aren't some people are
pretending like nothing's going on and
some people are all freaked out and that
creates tension and all kinds of
weirdness out there and then meanwhile
just down the street from you guys
there's thousands of people pouring out
into the street you know celebrating and
we wrote tested three of them at one
point we joined the Hollywood March the
first March that they did in Hollywood
which was probably I guess about two
weeks ago now yeah
and that was it was so weird because
after like being careful and all right
like suddenly you're so easy by the
moment you're just like let's go it was
such a weird thing because the protests
were going on for probably four or five
days before the one that we went to and
my boyfriend and I were having a really
difficult time because we wanted to be
there so badly from the start but then
we kept saying no we can't because what
then like this quarantine would be
thrown out the window we could just be
exposed to thousands of people that oh
yeah we did yeah and bring it back to my
grandparents in what in like one day but
then my grandparents were going to
Nevada they just got a house there so
they were going there the next day so my
dad my boyfriend I decided to go like
since we knew they weren't gonna be home
but it was just it's just
such complicated feelings about it too
because everything's reopening right now
and it's really hard to process because
you see so many people like in
restaurants again but you also see the
news and see that there are so many
cases still so it's just all very hard
to process yeah
I'm very confused the other day you were
like I'm thinking about going across was
did you go or no no I did it cuz it's
just so open they reopen reopen I want
to go but at the same time I'm like
believe me we kept crossroads and
business chair of the board you have
went to crossroads every night but I I
don't know it's just so weird and very
it's hard for my mind to process like
seeing everybody out as if nothing ever
really happened and people eating in
restaurants and and gyms are opening and
stuff and it's just very weird to
process so I was gonna go to Crossroads
the other day but then I was like well I
could or I could just do this restaurant
eating
I don't like I'd still eat so it's not I
just I miss being with people without
being tentative around it's like when
are we gonna you know it's not
necessarily the restaurant itself it's
like when when can we just walk into an
establishment and sit down and hang out
with our friends without thinking about
like yeah he's sick right now or am i
making somebody else sick or being
worried about washing your hands and all
that kind I mean is it two years in
vaccine probably life has changed
irrevocably and I know like naturally
we're as a country as a species we're
like and knock us down we'll get right
back up but like as we're seeing as
numbers continue to go up in these
states that have opened early like this
is no joke
you can just because like other crises
have popped up and stuff you can't
diminish this one just because the
government is going like now feel free
open up
you can't diminish this numbers continue
to rise I just read a story today about
a bunch of cats in Florida one of them a
nurse who was just like we all went out
to a bar all 16 of us got diagnosed with
Cova today
and she's like I'm IRA gret it she's
like I'm stupid I shouldn't have done it
you know like we all took off masks we
did not social distance I should have
known better now I'm paying for it so
she was urging others to take it more
seriously yeah so yeah even though the
guidelines are like hey we can go out
now like although tonight we're doing a
thing a streaming event for we got a
pop-up
yes moody's right and tell me about this
so like we got in in the movies a fake
fast-food joint called mooby's which was
first introduced in a movie I called a
movie I made called Dogma then we put it
in Jay and Silent Bob strike back it was
also when clerks - and most recently it
was in Jay and Silent Bob reboot so
these cats in town who've done themed
restaurants Derek Berry's genius comes
out of Chicago they did in Chicago this
save by the max pop-up restaurant so on
the TV show Saved by the Bell they would
hang out the max Reiner they recreated
it and so people were like this is great
so he took it to Los Angeles and moved
out here Derek did and started another
restaurant like took a rented the space
refurbished it turned it into the max
did that for a couple months then closed
it for a month then reopened it as good
burger from the movie the Nickelodeon
sketch comedy all that and then close it
and then reopen it as poyo Sur Manos
from Breaking Bad so he's in this theme
restaurant business where he flips the
theme every few months so he reached out
and was like what if we did movies
because they were supposed to be doing
something for clueless because it was
cool this is 25th anniversary and then
paramount I guess you know because the
corn team is about to happen like we're
not doing this they're locked away so he
had an open window and he's like you got
a fast-food joint what about movies so
we knew we couldn't open the restaurant
nobody going out nobody allowed to go
out but food delivery was still a thing
so Derek was like what if we did like
Happy Meal box like movie meals and
stuff and we can donate all the money
that we make you know because it'll be
like an advertisement for us eventually
doing the pop-up restaurant so a teaser
to see how it plays we donate all the
money to
a charity it was called no us without
you which was a charity for restaurant
workers that we're now without jobs
because of the quarantine and stuff so
his win went across the board and then
the only thing I said was like can we do
vegan option cuz I'm vegan he was like
yeah will you do whatever we're doing
we'll do a vegan version of it so we
offered this movie meal which was like
he'd been working with secret lasagna
the restaurant right a chef named chef
Royce so he was like we're with secret
lasagna can you work lasagna and I was
like you take lasagna put between two
pieces of bread as a lasagna sandwich
that's in the meal he's like alright
what else I was thinking put hater tots
in because they were just in Jay and
Silent Bob reboot tater tots and he put
chocolate covered pretzels in there and
that's from all rats I'll sign a card
and bam that's that'll be it so we
opened and first we were on post mates
and then we crashed the app twice la
post mates because people were hitting
it so hard
post mates very politely asked us to
leave because we couldn't do it
correctly until we went to another
reservation system where they wouldn't
deliver they could come and pick it up
at a point in time so now this is like
this was last month and it went really
well and and we raised like 10 grand I
think it was really wonderful but a
great indicator that if we actually do
the pop-up version haha people will come
so Derek and his crew Floyd is his art
art director went into their space and
completely turned it into what looks
like one of the movies from one of the
features I've done you can see like in
the place there's a quick stop like
exterior and an AR STX here from clerks
the movie I mean there's some Mallrats
exteriors like photograph city it's
selfie city all around the place so the
way it is now is we open officially
tomorrow you can't just walk up to you
can walk up to and look through the
windows but you can't just walk in
reservation system only go to movies pop
up calm they give you a time and a
reservation you pick your entire meal
it's almost a cashless exchange you
could do it all completely online so
that you show up you got your number
you're good to go
while you're there you could do all self
as you want we have a patio so if you
want to eat outside you can there's no
dining in the restaurant
because the quarantine and stuff but you
can take the food home of course but you
come and spend as long as you want and
then you're off how long is that gonna
be open for Holly like he says that they
do them for like one to two months based
on popularity so it'll only be there I
figure max like for like two months
but it sounds like it's super popular
why not just keep it rolling because I
honestly like to me I was like as a as a
business person or somebody you know
fancies himself business if it's selling
so well just keep doing it but Derek's
point is like that like look I love what
we're doing it's the limited Ron that's
what makes it for him he's like that's
what makes it exciting like they get to
switch kitchens chefs menus concepts and
then his entire crew gets to
artistically express themselves as they
remake the restaurant into something
else so I get it like on one level on
like hey if it's working let's make it
real but on the other hand that's not
what he does he's like for me the fun of
the job is like it changes all the time
he's like just like in your world he's
like you don't work on clerks every day
he's like you did it and then you do
others but you do the last word all
utter is up just like you know how it's
got to be wild reflecting on the fact
that you know when clerks came out that
was a very special time an independent
film you know that like this big
Sundance era where these Oh tours were
you know emerging the soda / exam of
course Tarantino right and then for you
to like work on like this incredible
movie with him I mean has to be a great
point of pride for you but what was that
experience like for you Harley working
with Quentin like what do we not know
about that mad genius I mean it was it
was a mind-blowing experience I thought
it was completely off the table because
I had auditioned for it and the audition
was really different from most you had
the opportunity to write
your own monologue from the perspective
of someone from the Manson family
because we all think of him as the
greatest writer like and so you would
imagine like what you're gonna audition
with like a monologue from acquitting
Terence yeah or he'll give you a
notebook with something but it's so
secretive about it that it stands to
reason that he's like I'm not gonna give
you anything look he gave you a real
scene that wasn't moved did he really
yeah so you saw pages of the movie
before did you have to sign like an NDA
yeah I had to at first I went to the
casting office and usually for every
audition you just get all the
information all the the scripts or the
sides or the audition papers rather it's
all online like you just get it sent
through email and a lot of the time if
it's really secretive they'll write your
name across it like Harley Quinn Smith
so you can't share it but for this and
it's the only time I've ever had to do
this you had to go in like a week or a
few days before the actual audition sign
like many papers and then they would
hand you one set of sides which was the
one scene which is actually in the movie
and then they also told me that I had
the option to write my own monologue so
I've been writing for my whole life and
so I felt I felt an obligation to to
definitely participate in that option so
I I ended up doing both and I mean it
went really well and I was really proud
of myself but like a months passed by
and I didn't hear anything so I was like
okay I was upset because that that was
one of the most insane opportunities
I've ever had he just just to even work
audition for and like I I just felt I
felt so so passionate about it and a
months pass I didn't hear anything and I
knew they
to film so I was like okay well Mike
yeah they served the food cuz it was uh
it was a I can't remember how many days
maybe I'm wrong but I'm pretty sure it
was over a hundred days of shooting if
not more but it's easily four months
yeah it was really long and then um one
day I actually my mom heard through her
friend who was involved in the movie and
she was like why didn't you tell me
Harley's in this movie and I was like no
she's not and her friend was like she's
on the call she III I see her like she's
on here and my mom was called me and was
like did you tell me and my dad and I
were together that day we had just shot
the first episode of this show called DC
daily it was that same day and I was
driving home and my mom was calling me
very chaotically over the phone and like
yelling at me and I was like I have
absolutely no idea what you're talking
about
i this movie's been shooting I'm not in
it and then my I called my manager and I
was like I I mean I don't think this is
true but do you have any idea what this
is about and she was like well I I
didn't want to tell you but for like the
past two or three weeks I have been
talking the casting because they told me
that Quentin really wants to find a way
to put you in the film mm-hmm and I was
like tell me and she was like but I
didn't hear anything was for sure so I I
don't know what this is about
and then the next day she called me and
she was like I don't know what's
happening but whatever you heard is
right you're gonna be in it that's so
crazy they you're on the call sheet and
nobody had called you too weird called
she they were like can you be here
tomorrow like did it happened quickly if
you're on the call sheet then I would
have suspect that it was the phone's
dryer hair yeah was for it was something
involving like costume in Harran and
hair makeup I don't remember
long after that I was shooting but it
was just it was so unexpected like on
that ship it was so far gone in my in my
head also caused one well I was gonna
say one of the only fights certainly not
one of the only fights but I fight with
my wife at the time cos Harley
auditioned and then there was no word
back and you know Harley was all sad and
[ __ ] and Jennifer came into the office
one day and she's like you know Quentin
don't you and I was like oh no not like
that I don't
I was like my daughter cuz I was like
number one I I don't have that
relationship with him where I'd call him
up be like hey can you put Mike in your
movie I said I I would never do that and
my wife goes well you don't make Quentin
Tarantino movies do you and I was like
that's not the point man I said but
number two imagine I do that and imagine
it worked and imagine she finds out
we're [ __ ] her life cuz then she
didn't earn it
it's something that we did and so it's
not she'll never be happy like you get
one moment of happiness where she's like
I got the part
then when the truth comes out we're
[ __ ] for life I was like no she wants
to be in this business this business is
99% [ __ ] rejection everyone gets told
no so let her learn man like this is how
you learn whether you want to be in this
business and then she got a [ __ ] yes
and I'm like she'll never learn he also
like really did not believe in me when I
got this audition and I was talking
about it and I mean it was such a big
thing they was crazy to even get an
audition for this film he had he saw
definitely less than a hundred people
for like every female part in the Manson
family and you weren't auditioning for
any specific person it was just a Manson
family member and I told my dad because
it was so exciting and he was like yeah
you're not gonna everybody I said you
know cuz she was like there's this movie
I really want
and I've been reading books about it and
I watched a documentary about the
subject matter and she's like have you
ever heard of a man named Charles Manson
and I was like yeah I think once in the
70s I'm like why do you ask
and she's like because I'm Quentin
Tarantino's making a movie about trust
Manson I was like oh my god I said kiddo
I want to be in that movie like ever
wants to be in that movie like you just
you got to lower your expectations I
literally said I was like do like your
mom when she married me and lower your
expectations man because that's like a
high bar I said I just read Jane Fonda
said she wanted to be in that movie
mm-hmm so I was like you know I'm a
parent I don't want to see her get her
heart broken and I did see it like when
she didn't get the part it was misery in
that house so I felt like you know put
her expectations in check she can always
be in a Kevin Smith movie but seemed
like it wasn't gonna happen but then it
happened I was like he's trying he's
trying to remember there was a period -
it didn't seem like it was gonna happen
where I was like you know what [ __ ] what
era - yeah you ain't gotta worry about
him I was so happy because like Quentin
Reservoir Dogs is one of the movies that
made me feel like who I could make a
move not because I looked at Reservoir
Dogs and said I'll do a jewel heist I
remember seeing the movie at on Third
Avenue in New York City want to go to
see matinee with my friend Benson and it
opens of course with you know them
talking about Madonna soaring like a
virgin so a very unlikely crew of people
dissecting pop culture essentially and I
remember like that is transformative I
was just like this counts as a dialogue
in a movie you can literally just talk
about some [ __ ] song like if this
counts as dialogue I think I could write
dialogue because me and my friends we
sit around we talk about Star Wars in
the same way so I could draw you a
direct line from Reservoir
to clerks I could draw your direct line
from pulp fiction which we saw on the
Croisette in in can like before anybody
else there's at the sean's no that's the
closet before anybody else at a preview
screening for critics and stuff before
it was in competition in that movie
shaped what Dogma became because Quentin
could do these breathtaking changes in
tone where he could be laughing and they
could shoot Marvin's face off and you're
like [ __ ] just got real
you know so the man influenced what I
did then I've met him of course and I've
known him for four years not like we're
not like super [ __ ] tight but he was
big fan of Believe It or Not Jane saw a
shape back that was a weird with chasing
amy absolutely loves I'm Charlie Rose
one day he was like my favorite movie
this year was chasing him he's like
Kevin Smith took a quantum leap so he's
always been a big figure in my career to
hear her go like he cast me like that
was that was everything you know as a
parent I was proud as [ __ ] but as a
professional I was like ah like that's
that's unlikely so no I was never like I
don't believe in for people that don't
know I mean you were you're on the spawn
ranch part of the Manson family I mean
those scenes were like so haunting and I
in and when you watch the movie it
doesn't take up a ton of screen time but
that was like a month of shooting right
yeah we were there for a really long
time you spent a lot of time with the
rest of the cast like creating that
family atmosphere yeah it was um it took
a long time to shoot what was on the
ranch because everything is on film too
so it takes that just even a bit longer
than it would just shooting digitally so
there was that aspect but also there's
just nothing but money and time like we
all just there was never any rush like
it was it was just very so relaxed
and it just really did feel like a
summer camp of the sorts we were all
hanging out we all didn't have our
phones we had to check in our phones
every day so we were all just together
and you don't let you bring phones on a
cell you me number one he's making a
period piece so he's like that wouldn't
be there man but number two he's smart
it just right everybody focuses on their
work your familial atmosphere cuz like
you only get that opportunity once
making a movie is like going to camp
like every movie is like summer camp and
some summer camps are more fun than
others and stuff but like it's always
this once-in-a-lifetime experience and
while you're doing it you're like it's
gonna be like this forever but smart
money understands that like this is a
moment in time even when you're making a
TV show episodically you think like oh
this goes on and on and on it ends and
when it ends you [ __ ] miss it like
because you realize I have to go back to
the real world and [ __ ] like I'd rather
just make pretend I'd rather be an
artist I'd rather play for a living so
it's smart that he's like leave your
[ __ ] cell phones off number one it's
smart for production and you don't have
to worry about people taking pictures
and stuff but number two it forces
everybody to embrace the moment live in
the moment and be like we're doing this
and this is never gonna happen again I
think every single person - would be
full of regret if after the experience
they were like oh I was on a Quentin
Tarantino set and I was not fully
immersed in the in the situation I was
on my Twitter yeah I would have so it
definitely provided for a really special
atmosphere when you got you made friends
with like yeah like loud pea-brain she's
still friends with him stuff I saw the
girl the girl who gets kilt in the pool
and spoilers you know and she's vegan -
what's it what's it like when Brad Pitt
shows up yeah I mean it's definitely
just very very surreal but it was also
really weird because his his picture
double looked like exactly the same as
him so a lot of the time and he's
playing a picture double -
like it's just it's just very weird but
there's one part in in the movie where
we're walking across a neighborhood
street and Brad and Leo are in a car
having this conversation and then they
see us walking in in Brad makes contact
with the character pussycat it was so
weird because just seeing both of them
together like in real life and at the
same time it was so much weird v I mean
it's it is pretty surreal because I feel
like both of them are like some of the
most mega fate like that's as hot that's
like they're on the top of the mega
famous side and it's gotta be this weird
experience like for you it's like I know
what these cats look like I'm so overly
familiar with them from so many movies
that they're kind of a part of my life
but they have no idea who I am then like
suddenly you know they're like hi how
are you and it's like being spoken to by
a movie like when a famous person you've
never met one of them ever to you just
say in real life like just like really
because I definitely wanted to know
about the story there's also my and my
dad likes to really be a part of
everything that I do and I'm about to be
it won't want the podcast to know it's
about a time in Hollywood three I'm
about to be in this show for a free form
called cruel summer and it's based in
the 90s and it's my first it's like my
first huge like I'm a series regular and
it's it's like I
I feel so thankful for it it's like a my
first big thing yeah like my first TV
show
here comes um and so but I like my dad's
face right I know I work very hard la I
have worked very hard for this I've gone
through a lot of pain as all actors do
like put in the work and I got this and
I'm very proud to say fully on my own
like I'm very much don't want my dad to
be a part of my acting career because I
want it to be completely separate from
him I've made that extremely clear
except for the films we make together
everything exact everything else I like
it's fully mine and I got it on my own
and I pride myself a lot on that
so I get my show and my dad is like I'm
gonna be on your show I'm gonna find a
way to get myself on this it's based in
the 90s and I'm a 90s icon and I'm gonna
be on the show and I was like [ __ ] no
there's literally no way I will leave I
will I will be so upset and feel so just
betrayed by the show was like I'm gonna
direct what I'm gonna be myself in what
and like I was like just and it makes
sense because it is in it is in the 90s
it's it's based on it spans three years
and it's from 93 to 95 and if I'm not
mistaken
94 Kevin looks so constipated I'm sure
there will be a reference I'm sure there
will be a reference at some point it's
gotta be right but I just would feel
better if you didn't have but this is
the father/daughter dynamic nutshell
daughter trying to break free and fly
and the dad holding on to every last bit
that he can to keep on for everything I
do I'm like see like um being she's like
sure and then I'm like what are you
doing God and she goes [ __ ] off man this
is young people's enter tired I've had
like I mean I I've so lucky in a sense
that I've I since my dad has been in
this industry for a long time I did have
like my foot in the door too
contacts with like agents and stuff like
that but I also in a sense it like
people always are like oh you just have
acting career because of nepotism which
is like yes I be I had a foot in the
door because of nepotism for sure but
I've had to face so much like a whole
different set of issues of people just
pre having pre judgments about me and
just thinking I looked not really
thinking of myself not thinking of me as
my own person and just thinking of my me
as an extension of my dad and so I
worked really really hard to make sure
that I am known as my own person for my
own talents and my own right and for my
own activism and not just as the child
of a famous person so with that being
said the path that I have worked very
hard to make on my own that is not
related to my dad's success I have very
certain feelings about my dad then
referring to himself as a 90s icon and
putting yourself in the show that I
that being said listen to our new
podcast together vegan abattoir which I
have no problem sharing time on it is I
I mean I'm very I'm so thankful for the
things that we do have together it's
just important to me that I also make a
career of my own that's only based on
the work that I've put in I think your
dad but of course I'm very honored to be
to be doing vegan avatar rich it's real
heartbreaking the day your kid outgrows
yeah yeah mine outgrew me like 15 years
ago she's just been like putting in the
time out of a sense of sweetness I fully
respect that's a jealous of your
relationship it is very sweet and the
the you know her
my wife refers to Harley is like she's
just beardless [ __ ] you man that's
not true but now she's like her own
individual like you know she used to gem
would always referred to like Harley as
my little twin and stuff like that and
then as Harley grew older like a lot of
her personality or interests and mine
are closed yeah I can't grow up in the
same [ __ ] house and not pick up some
things right so her and I are more alike
than her and Jennifer yeah which always
kind of leaves you know Jennifer mmm
feeling a little bit on the outside and
stuff like that but like you know I I
didn't you Jennifer asked the other day
we were talking about we watched some
[ __ ] show and somebody had a son and
she was like did you ever like miss like
having a way like a son and I was like
god no I'm like I'm Way happy with the
kid we got because she's so similar to
me like what if we had a boy and he was
similar to you [ __ ] that the fact that
that Harley's been decide show a couple
times and you haven't doing the podcast
together husband being together has been
right fun that has been the one thing
like where everyone else in our house is
vegetarian Nana pop Jen her mom my wife
but her and I are the only true like
plant-based vegan so we have that kind
of like hey man do you want to go to you
want to go to Crossroads hey man anyone
order from Cruiser hey man like we speak
that same language we've always been
very similar in other ways and stuff but
now there's that as well which has been
kind of adorable but also beneficial
like she literally saved my life by
being like come do this come do this and
like every time I pop something in my
mouth that's plant base which is every
time I pop something in my mouth I
generally think like I wouldn't have
been here we're not for her and not just
for her gum please do this she was a
vegan astronaut she'd been like you know
two years
vegan prior to me so she was able to
case the town and be like this is where
you can get this this is where you can
get this so I didn't enter it into a
state of ignorance trying to figure [ __ ]
out I had somebody to hold my hand and
be like here you would I know you and
you would like this and that made a
transition to a plant-based lifestyle
much easier you know for some people who
are like teetering like I'd like to do
it but what if I it's a mystery
yeah I had somebody who had like kind of
solved the mystery for herself
and so it was able to give me
information that made me feel way more
comfortable about leaving behind 47
[ __ ] years of a behavior 47 years of
eating a certain way so you know hats
off to you but it all does come back to
me because I did have this kid so and
you can save my life so hats off to me
having a kid you kept the weight off
like it's no small thing man that's
pretty incredible and it's really
powerful for you know everybody to see
that as well like do people still give
you [ __ ] about online stuff like that
for being vegan no no I mean no because
I'm very clear about like you know I'm
acerbic and and I could be funny about
it [ __ ] but I've kind of dealt with it
so many times online where somebody goes
at me hardcore and Twitter or in a
comment and Instagram I come back but
not in a way where I'm like [ __ ] you
were you're ignorant but just come back
and a pithy kind of well that makes that
comment seem ridiculous like that but
the it's been more beneficial than
anything else like for as many people
have been like oh you're vegan now many
three times as much they're in the
minority what I hear more often than not
is I went vegan because of you I lost a
bunch of weight because of you I'm
trying this because you now the big
thing I've been talking about lately as
I became I've been since since I became
a vegan and intermittent faster like you
know I was on up pretty much like a
sixteen eight o'clock for most of the
last two and a half years recently I've
gone to a more extreme clock which is
20/4 so 20-hour fast for our eating
every day pretty much every damn day
except for the days when I do 72-hour
fast which is fantastic Cleanse for the
body also releases you know
stem cells like its is crazy wonderful
for the body a lot of people
conventional wisdom has always been like
no you can't do that
your body will eat its muscles and [ __ ]
well not if you still have stored fat it
goes right to that and that's what the
body's supposed to be doing we're not
meant to be ting three meals a day
that's not been in our genetics for that
long and stuff and as Americans not only
do we eat three meals a day but those
three meals are giant you gotta eat a
big breakfast I've needin a breakfast in
over two years I don't break my fast
until minimum noon generally two or
three o'clock in the day or something so
man in talking about if' a bunch there
have been some people like you don't
know what you're doing and said I'm like
no I don't but I definitely been
watching a lot of people who know what
they're talking about talk about it on
YouTube and stuff and you know they're
they've got enough accreditation where
I'm like yeah I think I could try it and
I've tried it a number of times where
I'm like I know the benefits of this
this works so I started sharing like my
clock with people where I'm like oh I've
been this is my 72 hour or the fast
that's been the new pass along we're now
I've seen people going I'm now doing 16
eight now I'm gonna try for this like
it's it's you know I've liked over the
last 26 years being able to be like hey
I like Batman go see this hey alright
Star Wars goes it's really nice to be
able to be like a health and wellness
influencer now isn't that not crazy like
I was in Muscle & Fitness go [ __ ] fig
right now so like somebody been like I'm
taking health advice from him it's
foolhardy crazy Southwest Airlines saga
you know I remember when that whole
thing happened and how bananas that was
from that was really the beginning of
this whole thing a little bit yeah
that's why I start putting down sugar
after that when I was like I gotta get
sugar out of my life but now as a vegan
unfortunately sugar is well in my life
cuz like you know given up everything
else I'm not like well I'm giving up
[ __ ] sugar too so now you know you
allow yourself sugar and bread but I've
been able to cut bread out almost almost
completely I had some bread yesterday
but generally speaking I don't [ __ ] with
bread that much anymore but sugar that
is like it's it's hard to avoid sugar
and sugar still vegan you've you [ __ ]
with a lot of vegan junk food
yes I do that's the next mountain you
gotta climb I know to actually go vegan
with where I mean come
yes tell me about the pot like what is
the podcast angle like what's this gonna
be about she wanted to do it you know
she wanted to talk to people her idea
was like people ask me and I'm no expert
but I do know people who are experts so
like maybe I could be a conduit for that
I was like oh my god you could call it
vegan abattoir because like would be
slaughtering misinformation I think
that's how I hooked her she's like that
is actually clever so the idea is like
we sit down in the beginning we chitchat
and stuff and it's all of course
plant-based mostly and stuff but some
about our lives then we head into the
interview portion of the show so so far
she's been like going to talk to people
that she knows from the space who there
to people he spoke to I've spoken to my
friend daniella monet who is a activist
but she also has this cosmetics box that
she does with fellow vegan Evanna Lynch
and it's a monthly subscription box and
every month they give you a new box of a
cruelty-free and vegan cosmetics cool so
it's really awesome and who's the other
personal lady from being in street fair
and then I spoke to my friend Jessica
Shea who runs who's a founder and CEO of
vegan Street Fair which is there they
throw an annual event which has over 200
vegan vendors but she also does this
thing called vegan exchange which is
every Sunday it's a vegan it's a V and
farmers market basically which is its it
that it's um it's in North Hollywood
every single Sun was behind the federal
and they bring in like multiple trucks
going it's not happening right now
obviously but it's it is truly
life-changing
they've got look they got real green
food there but it's also a lot of cats
like eat this donut it's beginning yeah
and I
not only as a vegan but it's a thousand
calories in size so it is you go yeah
and you wind up walking out kinda heavy
so the idea is like we start the show
and then we kind of cut to her
interviewing somebody then we talk about
it afterwards and wrap up the show
that's cool the idea is it's for those
who are like you know the people who go
like what is it like and and what do you
miss those big and curious people who
are kind of teetering is just a little
more information not to like you know
drag them over or push them over but if
it helps you know and since they're
asking us on Twitter or and Instagram
comments and stuff this is a way to be
like well we went and spoke to somebody
who really knows yeah again you are one
of them you'll be you got to step up
your production game because you're used
to just sitting down and shooting the
[ __ ] me and like I'm done Chad there's
actually gonna be editing involved oh
wait so challenge actual challenge it's
to our interview talk to your friend for
30 minutes she comes back with the two
hair interviews is this enough I'm like
but like when were when we're recording
the opening in the ending it's we're
still trying to find out how to stay on
subject maybe the most predictable we're
just really trying to figure out how to
do it was on topic in as much as he's
not strictly vegan so it was like fine
he's a new pescetarian so we've been
speaking about that but it's like you
you how many how many episodes have you
recorded already when we get with you
before call let it be what it wants to
like it'll tell you what it wants to be
rather than saying it needs to be like
this like I think just in the doing
you'll find what
what it really wants to be cool man
I think we did it it just ends so I'm
being conscious of your time too
like I don't want to I think it's just
I'm she's probably used to me and I'm a
start guy yeah and like hey everybody
and then it ends with and everybody
we're done and this one's just kind of
like it happened you didn't know it
super nice to have you guys here I
appreciate it
pleasure thanks thank you vegan abattoir
premiering on June July's flat forms or
June 26 very exciting when's the TV show
coming out the cruel summer yeah
next summer 2021 so we gotta wait a
while so many projects student body it's
a film Austin metal or they can watch us
on celebrity show off on TBS thrown off
the show and you're writing like four
scripts right finished twilight of the
Mallrats that looks like it's shaping up
to be the next flick and then did
another draft of moose jaw's because
shutter was interested in it so it looks
like that's moving that's like the third
in yoga hosers awesome man you saw the
bus I got rid of the bus like sold the
bus off and stuff which sadly it would
come in handy now you want a house to
move around the country and not leave
well get it back thanks so much you guys
you're welcome here any time to come
back and talk to me again
alright peace
[Music]